este año para dar algunos ejemplos nos
convertimos en el miembro número 37 de
la ocde y recibimos la presidencia
pro-témpore de pro sur la alianza del
pacífico y la comunidad andina de
naciones
eso demuestra nuestro compromiso con el
multilateralismo y es prueba de un
compromiso regional en la búsqueda de
soluciones conjuntas que nos lleven a
que en el marco del llamado que hace la
organización de las naciones unidas
nadie se quede atrás la pérdida
acelerada de la biodiversidad es
actualmente una de las grandes
problemáticas mundiales la actual
coyuntura nos ha demostrado la estrecha
relación entre la salud humana y la
salud de los ecosistemas cuya
disminución pone en riesgo nuestra
supervivencia como especie
colombia se destaca por ser el segundo
país del mundo con mayor biodiversidad
por kilómetro cuadrado
tiene la fortuna de contar con el 50 por
ciento de los páramos del planeta en
medio de un territorio en el que el 30
por ciento corresponden a selva
amazónica colombia ha logrado una
reducción acumulada de 30.9 millones de
toneladas de co2 y hemos dado una lucha
contra la deforestación como en ningún
otro momento de la historia de nuestro
país por lo que incluimos la defensa del
medio ambiente como un propósito de
seguridad nacional
es así como reducimos y como hemos
reducido la deforestación en un 19% en
los últimos dos años y por medio de la
campaña de artemisa ejecutado nuestra
decisión de hacer de la diversidad un
activo estratégico y por eso hemos
recuperado más de seis mil hectáreas de
los parques nacionales naturales e
impedimos que 23.000 hectáreas de bosque
fueran deforestadas
mientras sembramos más de 35 millones de
árboles acercándonos a nuestra meta de
180 millones de árboles sembrados para
agosto del año 2022
el aumento de capacidad a energías
renovables ha sido otro de los aspectos
en los que hemos avanzado sobre la lucha
contra el cambio climático mientras en
el 2018 contábamos con 30 megavatios de
capacidad conectada a la red nacional
hoy hemos ampliado casi 5 veces esta
capacidad y llegado a más de 140
megavatios adicionales y con la meta
puesta de seguir creciendo la para
alcanzar una expansión 20 veces frente a
lo que teníamos en el año 2018 para que
en el año 2022 nuestro país supere los 2
mil 200 megas ratificamos también
nuestro compromiso para que el convenio
de minamata se haga realidad y donde
también expresamos que avanzamos como
nación en la ley que prohíbe el uso del
asbesto así como la promoción del uso de
los vehículos eléctricos a sí mismo
estamos a la espera de la aprobación por
parte del congreso de la república del
denominado acuerdo de escazú el cual
firmamos a finales del año pasado
el pacto de leticia que hace un año
anunciaba en el marco de esta asamblea
materialista parte de ese llamado
realizado por el gobierno colombiano y
en torno a él nos hemos unidos siete
estados para implementar un plan de
acción concreto que hoy contiene 52
acciones específicas para la
conservación y el desarrollo sostenible
de la amazonía reconociendo su
importancia como un ecosistema
estratégico para el planeta colombia ha
logrado que más de 2 mil 800 familias de
la amazonía hoy estén asociadas a
proyectos de reconversión ganadera
y a la producción de elementos no
maderables adicionalmente que más de 17
mil familias indígenas estén siendo
beneficiadas con proyectos de gobernanza
y economía sostenible y que 15.000 se
encuentren bajo esquemas de pago por
servicios ambientales para cerca de 200
19.000 hectáreas es una demostración de
lo que estamos alcanzando soñando con el
futuro y así como hemos liderado
acciones para proteger la amazonía los
bosques tropicales y los océanos
queremos convocar a todas las naciones
del planeta para que protejamos los
skorik los ecosistemas de alta montaña
colombia es el hogar de la mitad de los
páramos del mundo y hoy los invito a que
nos acompañen en la creación de una
estrategia global para la defensa de los
páramos con la que garantizamos la
supervivencia de estos ecosistemas y la
sostenibilidad de las comunidades que
los habitan
los páramos son verdaderas fábricas de
agua potable y el lugar de nacimiento de
las cuencas hídricas que irriga a gran
parte de nuestro territorio por eso la
convocatoria también se extiende a que
las naciones del mundo aporten recursos
y que entendamos que la protección de
los páramos es un deber universal
colombia es un país maravilloso habitado
por mujeres y hombres tan diversos como
nuestra naturaleza
hemos vivido los embates de la violencia
y de la pobreza y por eso estamos
empeñados en construir un futuro
sostenible a partir de la equidad la paz
real en la decisión social de edificar
prosperidad a partir de la verdad de la
solidaridad del apego a la legalidad y
el rechazo contundente a cualquier forma
de violencia
este gobierno ha diseñado una política
de paz con legalidad fundamentada en la
estabilización social y la consolidación
institucional de los territorios más
golpeados históricamente por la
violencia y la pobreza la política de
paz con legalidad está beneficiando a
más de 6 millones de compatriotas en sus
territorios con una inversión que supera
los 780 millones de dólares apoyando a
los más de 13.500 ex combatientes y
además cambiando sus vidas pero
cambiando las con un sentido de
propósito legal con garantías de no
repetición para más de 9 millones de
víctimas
quiero aprovechar este espacio para
honrar a las víctimas de la violencia en
mi país
igualmente que quiero exaltar la labor
de quienes todos los días realizan los
millones de esfuerzos que son necesarios
esfuerzos que los hacen realidad líderes
y lideresas sociales que construyen una
sociedad más digna más generosa y que a
pesar de las dificultades no cesan en su
empeño de construir un país para todos a
ellos ya todos los colombianos les
reconocemos esa vocación para construir
futuro para hacerlo sanando heridas
sanando las pero al mismo tiempo para
que la fraternidad en el marco de una
legalidad certera nos haga sentir
orgullosos hoy en colombia no hay
dilemas entre amigos y enemigos de la
paz hoy somos un solo país que avanza
sin importar si el viento está a favor o
en contra
las herramientas multilaterales han sido
claves para la contribución de la
comunidad internacional a este propósito
en especial en cuanto a la reparación de
las víctimas el fortalecimiento del
desarrollo rural la formalización de la
propiedad en los rincones remotos de
nuestro país destacó y agradezco el
acompañamiento de la misión de
verificación de la onu que es testigo de
excepción de los grandes avances de
nuestro gobierno en el propósito de
alcanzar una paz con legalidad es decir
una paz de verdad
desafortunadamente todos los esfuerzos
que realizamos tienen una amenaza común
el narcotráfico y las economías ilícitas
que generan
para mi país la lucha contra el
narcotráfico es un imperativo ético
porque engendra todas las corrupciones
participa de todas las cadenas del
delito y es el germen de la degradación
social
el narcotráfico nutre la trata de
personas el tráfico de armas la
extracción ilegal de minerales la
deforestación el contrabando el
narcotráfico fractura a las familias
quiebra los valores sociales atenta
constantemente contra la vida de
millones de personas en todo el mundo y
promueve la desigualdad sembrando en
tierras pacíficas el odio la violencia y
la muerte
el narcotráfico trasciende las fronteras
y mi país ha sido víctima de este hecho
deleznable este crimen transnacional
demanda la actuación conjunta de todos
los estados con sentido de
corresponsabilidad y en estos desafíos
comunes en los que debemos actuar de la
mano sin dubitaciones con energía y sin
vacilaciones hay que hacerlo por un
deber con las nuevas generaciones
la coyuntura ocasionada por el cómic 19
también se ha convertido en una amenaza
para el resquebrajamiento de las
inequidades sociales
esta crisis mundial ha evidenciado tanto
las fortalezas como las debilidades de
las herramientas multilaterales
por un lado demostró que aún es
necesario definir mejores mecanismos de
cooperación en circunstancias de crisis
al tiempo que esas mismas herramientas
han conducido la búsqueda de soluciones
conjuntas para superarla por ejemplo en
cuanto a la adquisición de vacunas
el trabajo mancomunado con
organizaciones como la organización
panamericana de la salud y la
organización mundial de la salud ha sido
crucial durante todo este año 2020 y lo
continuará haciendo mientras podamos
encontrar posibles soluciones ante esta
crisis mecanismos como kóvacs donde
colombia participa activamente son
fundamentales para que varias naciones
colaboren en la búsqueda de la
distribución de una eventual vacuna la
solidaridad entre naciones y la
colaboración permanente son esenciales
si queremos atravesar con éxito el
temporal de la pandemia
la pandemia está haciendo un punto de
inflexión para pensar en un futuro
sostenible y justo ahora que estamos en
miras de reactivar nuestras economías y
nuestra vida productiva es necesario que
la sostenibilidad ambiental sea el punto
de encuentro para la construcción de un
mundo más sostenible más responsable
dentro de este marco la protección de la
democracia regional es un elemento
fundamental las amenazas a la democracia
que vemos hoy atentan contra las
libertades de las naciones y también
impiden la integración regional y la
cooperación para la superación de retos
como los que actualmente enfrenta la
humanidad el régimen dictatorial de
maduro se sostiene con los recursos del
narcotráfico alberga terroristas y es
una amenaza constante para la democracia
en la región y en todo el mundo las
constantes violaciones a los derechos
humanos por parte de la dictadura las
que denunciamos en nuestro país y las
que hemos denunciado en los foros
internacionales incluyendo la corte
penal internacional han sido confirmadas
recientemente por la organización de
naciones unidas porque porque lo que se
busca en venezuela con los crímenes de
lesa humanidad es perpetuar la tiranía
y todos absolutamente todos en la
comunidad internacional tenemos que
rechazar esa situación y necesitamos
hacer un llamado enérgico a todas las
naciones del mundo para que lleven sus
voces reclamando elecciones
verdaderamente libres y no la orquesta
prefabricada electoral a la que se
quiere llevar al pueblo venezolano en
este mes de diciembre únicamente para
perpetuar la dictadura por eso tenemos
que rechazar ese proceso que busca
legitimar la dictadura de maduro hoy
colombia le dice al mundo que mira al
futuro con optimismo con la frente en
alto y llama a sus líderes para unirnos
como nunca antes desde que existe esta
organización para que juntos superemos
las dificultades inéditas que estos
tiempos nos han puesto en frente
estoy seguro de que en nuestra propia
humanidad está nuestro más nuestra mayor
fortaleza
estoy convencido que cuando miremos
hacia atrás y recordemos estos difíciles
meses encontraremos pueblos resilientes
que le pusieron el pecho a la historia y
navegaron con sabiduría de las
tempestades señores presidentes y jefes
de delegación el futuro está en nuestras
manos muchísimas gracias